[Music]
ah boring that's how they do it yeah
that's how they do it
Jesus
I'm putting the worst resistance of them
all right
we'll see we'll see
I'm not sure this works I think it was
nice
yeah but a few is foreign
oh solid boys
foreign
thank you thank you okay guys it makes
me very happy yeah
default is kind of wearing some ah
different okay we're back now
okay
oh wow
not actually I actually have to
calculate and then everything sort of
falls apart
so I think here if you manage
you need to brush up on my grand prix
attack yeah day three with A3
specifically that was the one that was
the culture
everybody
[Music]
I needed to take first what
so dumb
actually need to take first
if you say so
it's not a completely
oh boy
fighting fighting yeah maybe I'm the one
who's fighting now I'm always fighting
don't worry I'm always tomorrow's
fighting yes I can tell you that what's
this trick is that trick no there's no
trick okay
look at him
that's what schedule Champion looks like
yeah instead of schedule looks like yes
he's confessing his fears
welcome Brave I am no I'm not I'm not
brave
oh so solid so solid
what a scared notable Champion looks
like yeah
what do I do now okay
oh
he wasn't scared after all
okay
hmm
[Music]
look at Gary there yeah
what the hell's my move yeah no morning
hi Gary would do yeah
yeah still I don't have a threat but
continue
this one
yeah doing it too
ah okay yeah time hold on okay one white
one yeah